hello everyone I'm along and welcome to
my channel where today something very
exciting is happening
I am unboxing this I know it looks
exciting but seriously this is a
custom-made sharzad statute that was
finished in May this year so there's a
long lead-in time to me unboxing it
right now and I'm gonna be honest I'm
kind of nervous it was made by somebody
can find on social media called legion
of the cow who was just this incredible
sculptor and paint and just artist in
general and he makes a ton of really
cool pokémon stuff and this one is mine
but basically being that it's custom
made there isn't any like tailored fun
situation so that he could ship it to me
and we didn't want to send it through
the mail because we were really worried
about it breaking I don't know if you've
ever used the postal service before but
those guys don't give a [ __ ] about
fragile stickers so we basically waited
until I went to Canada knowing that I
would do this for walk because Ubisoft
is the EA motive is there and last week
I happened to be there visiting EA
motive so I messaged him and was like
hey I just found out that I'm going to
Canada I literally found out last Friday
and so he drove from Ottawa to meet me
in Montreal so that I could finally get
this chars on I basically just had a bag
as carry-on that I put on in my seat and
then I carried this by hand the entire
time and I'm still really worried about
it being broken when I open it I'm I'm
scared it was very careful with it but
there was one point where it was going
through the security I had to put it on
you know one of the trays and it went
through the security and somehow when it
came out on the outside it was no longer
on the tray meaning it tipped off which
like just terrified me I don't know how
that happened I guess that maybe the box
is so light that it just kind of flipped
I don't know I really hope it's okay if
it's broken I mean it's one of a kind
it's nothing we can do about it
so we did our best and let's open it up
alright it's packaged well good news
very well packaged it looks like this is
probably gonna be pretty snug so okay
it's in two pieces but not not on a
broken way it's intentional
two pieces Oh what do you wanted that I
thought it would be Wow nice nice metal
rod hanging out there if you haven't
want to stab yourself okay I see you I
see a coal there's a cool of it
everything looks good so far you guys it
looks so good already oh my god so while
I'm in bossing this I thought I would
mention I stopped collecting and I made
a video about that last year and the
reason for that is because San Francisco
is stupidly expensive and I needed to be
more responsible with money so that I
didn't stop to death basically but there
were two things that I really wanted to
get that I've been looking for for years
that I haven't gotten one of those is a
moderate suit and thankfully first full
figures brought out in a matter of sue
statue and they're bringing out a bust I
have a matter Asif that was my loss
unboxing the other one was chars on who
there are tons of big Azov is in action
figures that have joints that I find
really ugly but I've never seen a
Charizard statue until now look at it so
not only is it something I had
custom-made and like you know put a lot
of thought and actually getting into my
hands but it's also really like the loss
statue that I desperately wanted so this
is the Charizard look how gorgeous that
is like all of that shading and the
different colors and it's got a really
nice shine on it I love the tail so this
is the chars own he looks really shiny
because my lights so harsh but there's
not much I can do about that and face oh
you guys okay it's just like hold him by
his tail a little bit look how goddamn
cool that is his eyes are just amazed
so then going to group definitely put
this down piece number two is the base
which is like equally as impressive as
Charizard I've seen photos obviously
this is incredible so this is what the
base looks like before chars on has been
added to it just like loads of splashes
of color like that file looks so hot
underneath ah awesome so I'm gonna put
Shahrzad on he now make sure that put
him in the right way
he slots in to his base like so and it
looks like it pretty much made it safely
from Canada to San Francisco so I feel
pretty good about that
no damage that I can see but to kind of
try to explain how he made it um from
someone who doesn't know how this kind
of statue is made so I think this is
made out of putty it's a kind of putty
that I believe it dries wet which means
that you can like customize it a lot but
it means it needs to be fired or baked
so that it hardens before you can paint
it and I know that you did a lot of like
hand detailing but also some airbrushing
to get the paint to look just right and
I feel like that was just like
completely perfected here so that is it
for me geeking out on this video I'll
leave a link to in the description below
it's a way you can find Legion up the
cowl and see more of his stuff which is
just so freakin cool that is it for me
today you guys I was very excited to
make this video very glad that had
worked out and I have to give a huge
thank you to everyone whose names on
screen right now for supporting me on
patreon
I've bought this cool background so my
videos don't look like this shot in a
prison anymore so that's cool and that
is it for me to everyone I will see all
of you lovely people next time Oh